[Musique]
vous serez placé
dans un établissement avec d'autres
délinquants juvéniles violents,
ils pourraient apprendre de leurs erreurs
en pensant à leurs péchés,
bienvenue pour incarner le seigneur,
vous avez beaucoup souffert dans votre jeune
vie,
Jackie va revenir pour nous,
bénis-moi père pour  j'ai péché ça
fait trois jours depuis ma dernière confession
oui
c'est moi dans le coin
nous ne savons pas combien de mandrins sont là-
bas
super
une autre poupée tueuse avec une plante ombragée
combien d'entre vous êtes là
attendez vous avez un couteau ouais je  ont un couteau
ils les ont distribués à l'orientation
ne me faites pas revenir là-bas
j'allais conquérir le monde qui n'était pas de cette chienne de l'enfer glenda c'est tellement agréable de voir tes doux
visages
maman qui diable est nika te
percer  ma mère est une meurtrière psychotique qui
pense qu'elle est amoureuse de moi et elle m'a
coupé tous les membres et elle
m'a gardé enfermé ici pendant un an maman est une
meurtrière maman est une lesbienne
il y a un mal parmi nous et nous
devons l'affronter
je  je suis le mvp du meurtre en série
je veux dire j'ai tué plus de gens que tu
n'as d'abonnés insta
n'arrête jamais de te battre
oh elle vient de mourir chucky
je
me lève
et ça ne m'a même pas pris trois jours
[Rires]
[Musique]
toi